...may be able to help.
>> Tucker: A CLASS THIS SPRING
AT OHIO STATE UNIVERSITY IS
DEDICATED TO WHAT IT CLEARLY
REGARDS AS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
IN THE COUNTRY, WITH A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
OF COURSE IT’S STRAIGHT WHITE
MEN.
BE A MAN, MASCULIITY RACE AND
NATION IS THE NAME OF THE CLASS.
ATTACKS WHITE MEN FOR PRIVILEGE
IN A BUNCH OF WAYS.
TITLES LIKE ADVERTISING AND THE
CONSTRUCTION OF VIOLENT WHITE
MASCULINITY, APPEARS TO ROTATE
AROUND HOW WHITE MEN HAVE VICK
TIMEIZED EVERYONE.
CHRIS TY IS A LONG-TIME DEMOCRAT
WHO THINKS ABOUT THESE ISSUES
AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
CHRISTY, WITHOUT GETTING INTO
HOW UNBELIEVABLY UNBELIEVABLE
EVERY WHITE STRAIGHT MAN IS,
GOES WITHOUT SAYING, AS AN
ELECTORAL STRATEGY THIS IS
REALLY COMMON ON THE LEFT EVEN
FROM ELECTED OFFICIALS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DISMISSING
WHITE MEN AS BAD.
IS IT KIND OF BAD POLITICS TO,
LIKE, TELL TENS OF THOUSANDS,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
YOU HATE THEM FOR WHO YOU ARE?
THEY’RE NEVER GOING TO VOTE FOR
YOU.
>> HAH OHIO STATE PROFESSOR WAS
NOT TAPPED TO WRITE POLICY THE
LAST TIME I CHECKED.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> I DON’T SEE ANY POLICIES
COMING OUT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY MEANT TO DEMONIZE WHITE
MEN.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
JUST ALL OF THEM, BEGINNING WITH
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, HIRING
SET-ASIDES AND ALL THAT.
YOU’RE RIGHT, NOT JUST OHIO
STATE, THE SENIOR ELECTED
DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES LAST WEEK
ATTACKED THE NEGOTIATIONS OVER
DACA ONLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
BEING LED BY, QUOTE, FIVE WHITE
MEN, IF THAT WAS INHERENTLY
DISCREDITING.
>> THAT IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT,
SOMETHING THAT I THINK BRINGS UP
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE, HE HAS IN
HIS ONE YEAR IN OFFICE ALREADY,
MAILED THE LEAST DIVERSE CABINET
IN A GENERATION.
HIS COURT APPOINTMENTS ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY WHITE MALES.
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT AS A WOULD
WOMAN YOU THINK, HMM.
WOMEN AREN’T THE ONLY PEOPLE ON
THE PLANET, SHOULDN’T BE THE
ONLY PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF
POWER, PRESIDENT TRUMP SEEMS TO
FEEL THIS WAY.
>> Tucker: YOU AREN’T SUPPOSED
TO ATTACK PEOPLE ON THINGS THEY
CAN’T CONTROL, SEX, RACE.
THEN YOU HAVE ELECTED OFFICIALS
OPENLY ATTACKING PEOPLE NOT
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY SAID OR
THEY’VE DONE, ON THE BASIS OF
SEX AND RACE, THAT’S PROFOUNDLY
ALIENATING TO PEEP.
SAME RACE AND SEX, MAYBE PEOPLE
OF OTHER GOOD CONSCIENCE.
>> MAYBE SAYING PEOPLE FROM
CERTAIN AFRICAN COUNTRIES ARE
PROBABLY, COULD ALL BE SEEN THE
SAME WAY, NOT IN A POSITIVE WAY?
>> Tucker: HE DIDN’T SAY THAT,
HE ATTACKED THE COUNTRY.
WHATEVER.
IF YOU DON’T LIKE THAT TALK
DON’T ENGAGE IN IT.
SAYING NAUGHTY THINGS ISN’T AN
ANSWER.
THIS IS EVERYWHERE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF
DEMOCRATIC OFFICIALS ATTACKING
WHITE MEN FOR BEING WHITE MEN.
WHAT IS THE IDEA HERE, WHAT ARE
YOU GETTING AT?
>> THEY’RE NOT ATTACKING WHITE
MEN FOR BEING WHITE MEN, THEY
ARE ATTACK THE IDEA THINGS
AREN’T DIVERSE, IF YOU WANT TO
HAVE SINCERE CONVERSATIONS IN
AMERICA ABOUT THE WAY THINGS ARE
AND THE WAY WE CAN IMPROVE OUR
COUNTRY WE ACTUALLY TO HAVE
LISTEN TO MORE VOICES THAN JUST
THOSE.
>> Tucker: HERE’S SALLY BOYNTON
BROWN, RUNNING FOR DNC CHAIR,
RUNS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
IDAHO, SHE SAID MY JOB IS TO
SHUT ON UP ON THEY ARE WHITE
PEOPLE, SHUT THEM DOWN.
>> I REMEMBER THAT COMMENT AND
IT WAS KIND OF STUPID.
WHAT SHE MEANT BY THAT,
SOMETIMES THE PEOPLE IN POWER
NEED TO JUST SIT BACK AND DO
LISTENING AS OPPOSED TO ALL THE
TALKING.
>> Tucker: SHE’S SAYING NOT
EVERY WHITE MAN IS IN POWER, IN
FACT THE LIFE EXPECTANCY FOR A
LOT OF WHITE MEN IS GOING DOWN.
NOT TRUE FOR ANY OTHER GROUP.
NO POWER AT ALL.
THEY’RE DYING YOUNGER THAN OTHER
PEOPLE.
I GUESS IT’S THE ASSUMPTION THAT
BECAUSE OF YOUR RACE AND SEX YOU
HAVE POWER, IS IT SELF, THE
DEFINITION OF RACIST.
WE BOTH AGREE.
WHY SAY THAT CRAP IN PUBLIC,
WHAT IS THE POINT?
>> THAT WAS A PRETTY DUMB
STATEMENT SHE MADE.
BUT THE SENTIMENT BEHIND IT IS
ONE WE CAN AGREE WITH, WHICH IS
THAT SOMETIMES THE PEOPLE IN
POWER NEED TO BE DOING THE
LISTENING INSTEAD TALKING.
>> Tucker: I DPLEETLY AGREE, I
FEEL THAT WAY WITH NANCY PELOSI,
SHE CAN SHUT UP AND LISTEN.
IT’S NOT ABOUT RACE AND SEX.
HOW CAN A PARTY THAT ATTACKS
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
RASHT EXPECT TO WIN ANY VOTES
FROM THOSE PEOPLE?
>> I DON’T BELIEVE THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOES ATTACK
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
RACE.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
SEEN A LOT FROM THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> Tucker: WOW.